Are you single by the way?
No.
Oh, you're not.
I'm not.
But do you have any dating advice
for me 'cause I'm single.
I've been single for six years.
I cannot believe you're single.
So, so single.
I'm making a list.
Oh, I'm so good at...
I'm like Emma from the Austen.
I'm a good matchmaker and I'm on it.
I wasn't even asking for that, but my goodness.
Good, okay.
It's my favorite.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, I was single for a long time,
Like very purposefully.
Yes.
You know, needed a long time,
like four years to transition and honor,
and just do my own thing.
I got to have a relationship with myself for the first time.
I'm the mother of kids and daughter.
Yeah.
So, it's all out there.
But like in the last two years, I am fascinated
with discussing how it is to be single in this modern age.
Yeah, well, I mean the last two years was...
It's not an easy time to be single.
And also, dating in New York, like I've never...
I'm English and the whole concept of dating
in America is so different over there.
How so?
Like if you kiss someone
in England, you're basically together.
Like this whole, 'I'm dating a few people' thing,
I'm like, "God, what is hap..."
Like how does anybody manage that?
I must be British.
You've got to go to England.
Yes, yes.
I'm not a juggler.
No.
If I met someone on a dating app
and we like said "hello", I'm like,
"Oh, we're together now."
We are together, yeah.
And I shouldn't even talk to someone else
on the dating app
because the guy who like owns it is watching me.
Yes.
And he'll know,
and I can't do that.
Yes.
Oh my God!
I'm British then.
I'm living-
You're British
In the wrong country.
I watched the Bachelorette
and I couldn't believe that she can be kissing all of them.
And like, how does that work?
I feel the same way.
I'm like, how can you be like..
Because as soon as I kiss someone I'm into...
Like that's it.
Like, I'm projecting and it's going far.
I did have a few years, many years of my life
when I was young, I would walk into a place and I'd be like,
"You", grab the tie, kiss, make out with, and then, "Bye".
Oh, amazing!
And now I am like...
Hello.
I mean, look at the way I'm dressed.
Does this not tell you everything?
I am so different now.
You've still got it in you,
you just need to come out with me.
And I'm gonna take you out in the time.
We're gonna find...
Sienna!
(audience applauding)
Let's get this full circle on.
We're doing it.
We know how to have fun.
We've been doing it for years. Let's do it.
And also, English boys, I think are quite nice.
(audience laughing)
Well, speaking of all things British,
is it true that you love this candy?
It's an English candy.
Which? What?
I mean, yes, probably.
Hold on.
Oh, thank you.
What?
Yes, I found out your favorite candy.
Drewski, what have you done!
Like it with the yellow ribbon.
It goes.
I feel like I'm at, sort of,
like a bridal shower or something.
Yes, I got some good intel from Harryana, our producer.
She's great.
And she said
that this was your favorite candy.
How did you get this in America?
Oh my God!
Oh, good, good.
Okay, good.
They're so delicious.
What're they called?
Minstrels, Minstrels.
Minstrels.
I'm gonna have one.
(upbeat music)